without that porn move he was in for a
load of suffering half of yeah 50
hundred moves of suffering so he kind of
maybe wanted to shorten that suffering
by taking a risk it's understandable it
was a mistake but I blame the early
decisions swapping the Queens swapping
the Rooks
especially when you're facing the two
Bishops I've said this many times like
when you're playing against two Bishops
you need to accelerate the play you need
to keep pieces on the board the more
pieces get traded the stronger the
Bishops become and blacks Bishops you
know I you know you know the good news
about this surely we're gonna get hands
interview now
surely I mean I think he's just
threatening to win a piece there's no
check probably a very clever move but
has calculated this Gary giving up his
Knight deflecting away the oh yeah he
has calculated it of course check the
white king driven away and next move the
night falls Hans takes the win Wow Come
Back by Hans Nema and he ties the match
against Anish giri game four will happen
and if we have a winner in that game